i'm mark leda and i create the videos
you see on my channel soft white
underbelly
i've just recently started a new
subscription channel that'll be
replacing the patreon channel that i've
had for the last year or two
this new channel will be watchable on
android and apple mobile devices roku tv
apple tv and amazon fire
as well as the softwiteunderbelly.com
website which is where you subscribe to
it for 10 a month you'll get ad-free
videos and a lot of exclusive content
that is not going to be on my youtube
channel the videos that i post on
youtube that are demonetized i'm no
longer going to post on youtube i'm just
going to post them on this new
subscription channel
it'll be like additional content to what
i post on youtube i'm still going to be
uploading on youtube every day but just
not those videos so there'll be some
exclusive content that'll be just on
this channel but also be uploading every
day to youtube so that won't really look
much different than it is today
so for those that are looking to support
what i do or are just into the content i
produce and want to see more of it
this would be a place to do that
there's a one week free trial to see if
you like it
i thank you for watching i thank you for
subscribing whether you watch on youtube
or on this new subscription channel
thank you very much
you